let's have a look at what it would take
for either
of these two men to make it into the
white house clearly
for joe biden it's looking like a more
straightforward path with 253 electoral
college votes all he needs
is to potentially i should say all he
needs is no by no means easy
is to win in pennsylvania that takes him
over the line pretty clearly but as i
say that's not not straightforward
particularly when you look at
the state itself now let's consider
pennsylvania traditionally
very much democratic so you see they
voted for john kerry in 2004 then for
barack obama but it flipped
to donald trump in 2016 and it's mainly
this
white uh working-class vote that donald
trump really
won with i think in a state in a county
and we're kind of digging into
beneath the state lines looking at
county level data in a county like
lackawanna that's scranton
though joe biden has managed to get
uh up a bit compared with last time
around he is winning
in lackawanna but here's the thing he's
not doing the same in
every county in pennsylvania there are
some and this is uh colombia
a county that was donald trump before
he's managed actually to maintain
his lead in this this more rural part
of the state of pennsylvania and that's
rather interesting because it suggests
that there are some parts where his vote
is holding up but it's not all just
about pennsylvania clearly pennsylvania
could well decide this it's that state
that we've been looking at
for so long that pivot state but there
are other routes that potentially joe
biden
uh could take if he were able to win in
nevada and arizona you can see that also
takes him up
to 270 but what about for donald trump
we'll clear that off and consider how he
could potentially get into the white
house if he wins alaska we assume he's
going to win alaska but also
pennsylvania look at his number getting
up a bit but it's
got to go a bit further he's got to win
in north carolina potentially and in
georgia as well we'll color those in red
as well
and there he is 268 and he's really
still got to win
arizona another state which went
republican last time
but who knows this time around however
he'll certainly be happy that he got
florida do you remember that
early on in the night florida went to
donald trump and it was a reminder
wasn't it that all those polls
saying that he wasn't going to win this
time around well they were wrong
look at what happened this time this is
showing a republican support the poll
versus what actually happened look he
was better in florida than the polls
better in iowa than the polls better in
minnesota
than the polls suggested better in ohio
as well and better
in texas what we do know for sure is
that all those pollsters
once again they've got egg on their
faces
you